Mother's Day is approaching and the
channel wants to pay tribute to those women
who work hard to support
their families, each with their own style, each
in a different way, but in the end with
the heart of a mother who gives
everything for her children.  children come with me to learn about
the story of jennifer
lópez below I know that the mothers in the
community work a lot and it is something
that is very important for the community to
know is that the mothers after
working all day with the
family with the children  and also their
work they also need to do
things around the house that is important that
the people and the community know that
the mother's schedule is one that never
ends we are always working
uniforms they really know I like it I
like being here with my family  and I know
that it is a little that I will do sometimes but
the thing that I like is that I can I can
eat my lunch with my son
and in the pri I could not do that every day
that I can eat with my son and I can
picking up my son from school are
things that I really couldn't do
before the pandemic the things that are most
important to me are my family
I love my son very much and my husband
and also my dog without the support of my hu
band I couldn't  do what I do with
my work and also with my
efforts with the community but every day
we get up early
we get ready very quickly and then
we go to school to drop off my son and
after three hours
I am the person who picks up the child
and  then we do here at home
making lunch eating quickly because it
is time to participate in his classes
berchot this after that
we also do homework it
is time to participate in his
class what is my son doing we are
pregnant it was one of the most
special moments for  my husband and I because
we loved children and we know that it will
be a moment that will change our
lives and we do it together it was also the
moment that changed everything for  o is very
nice and I am very grateful to make
a mother
I love my son is is my life
reported for is nothing in Spanish
natalia lanzelotti